le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais dans une île
où le chômage est très important trouver
un emploi n'est pas chose facile
face à ce constat certains décident de
créer leur propre emploi et de se lancer
dans l'aventuré de l'entrepreneuriat
il s'agit là d'un véritable défi pour la
réussite duquel des qualités sont
indispensables comme la persévérance les
connaissances le savoir faire le courage
mais même quand on possède toutes ces
qualités
rien n'est acquis et un soutien
financier et moral n'est pas de trop
pour arriver à réaliser ses projets
alors qui peut aider à devenir chef
d'entreprise
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
c'est à sainte clotilde dans la zac
finette pu régis 36 ans se rend à son
travail comme tous les matins depuis
maintenant sept ans régis fait le tour
du bâtiment pour dire bonjour au reste
de l'équipe
cette entreprise spécialisée dans les
mécanismes des portails automatiques est
composé de 10 personnes et régis en est
le patron avant d'avoir sa propre
entreprise
régis était salarié travailleur assidu
et motivé
il n'avait pas peur d'assumer beaucoup
de responsabilités au fil du temps il a
donc pris pleinement conscience de ses
compétences et a réalisé qu'il pouvait
mettre ses capacités à son propre
service
l'idée de devenir patron est né et a
longuement mûri
jusqu'au jour où il a décidé de franchir
le pas prévoyants régis a mis ses
économies dans son entreprise et cette
armée de courage et de persévérance
ce qui m'a donné envie d'être patron en
fait simplement c'est après le statut de
salarié
je me suis posé question existentielle
sur sur ce que ce que j'étais capable de
faire ce que j'avais envie et je me suis
rendu compte qu autour de moi il y avait
plein de structures qui aidé à la
formation et la création d'entreprise
parmi ces aides ya eu le challenge des
jeunes créateurs organisé par le conseil
général
c'est vrai que moi ça a été un élément
déclencheur dans le sens où le fait de
se défend d'être devant un jury de
vendre son entreprise
vous donne vraiment une grosse fierté
une assurance un petit peu déterminants
pour la suite des événements donc c
était accompagné d'un chèque pour moi à
l'époque de 3100 euros qui a permis de
faire des investissements dans du
mobilier dans des ordinateurs qu'ils
poil au bon moment en fait donc c'est
vraiment d'une activité qui a pris la
mayonnaise est là elle a bien elle a
bien pris et
concentrer essentiellement sur toute
l'activité automatismes et contrôle
d'accès alors humainement c'est je me
sens je me sens bien je suis vraiment
bien et me reposer je maîtrise sur tout
ce que je fais
l'entreprise elle est connue et reconnue
le bouche à oreille nous fait avancer le
travail bien fait nous fait pouffer
continué de progresser et
c'est toujours avec plaisir que je je
continue l'aventuré
les produits sont révolus de tous les
ans il faut se former il faut il faut
suivre un petit peu tout ce qui est une
nouvelle technologie
donc c'est vraiment
une activité où je me plais et
où les gens qui sont avec moi aussi se
plaisent et ses skis et c'est ce qui est
vraiment plaisant dans dans ce conflit
régis est devenu patron à seulement 29
ans et gère aujourd'hui d'entreprises de
10 personnes avec un chiffre d'affaires
en perpétuelle évolution
ce chef d'entreprise fait partie de
cette jeunesse réunionnaise motivé
ambitieuse qui apporte du dynamisme à
l'économie locale
non seulement ces personnes créent leur
propre emploi mais elle participe
activement à lutter contre le chômage
car elle crée aussi des emplois pour de
nombreux réunionnais c'est pour ces
raisons que le conseil général encourage
les entrepreneurs avec diverses web mais
aussi des concours comme le challenge
des créateurs
ce concours apporte bien plus qu'une
somme d'argent pour le département c'est
une façon de montrer son soutien à des
personnes qui dynamisent l'économie
réunionnaise tout en leur apportant une
reconnaissance bien méritée
le conseil général nous apportons des
aides sociales aux personnes les plus
démunies ou est plus vulnérable mais la
solidarité sociale peut engendrer
également amené de la solidarité
économique
la preuve au travers justement la 16e
édition des challenges des créateurs des
personnes bénéficiaires de rsa qui
créent leur emploi accompagnent et
justement par les aides mais aussi la
technicité de tout le réseau point
chance elle a dit et vous voyez que il
vient de très belles réalisations et des
entreprises qui peuvent à la fois créer
son propre emploi mais les emplois pour
les autres également
le conseil général apporte énormément de
soutien aux réunionnais démunis mais
l'objectif est aujourd'hui de permettre
un transfert de la solidarité sociale
vers la solidarité économique
à chaque fois que cela est possible
comme régis beaucoup de réunionnais ont
pour volonté de faire avancer les choses
ambitieuse courageuse volontaires
compétentes
ces personnes participent activement à
l'évolution de la réunion
des concours comme le challenge des
créateurs doté de 7500 euros permet à
ces réunionnais de trouver une
reconnaissance gratifiante
comme pour régis ce concours a changé la
vie de nombreux chefs d'entreprise 80%
des sociétés récompensées sont encore en
activité ce qui est considérable et rien
que pour l'édition 2013
les 170 concurrents en lice dont 54
femmes avaient créé 270 emplois le
conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais